so good morning everybody it's very rare
to have the opportunity to introduce
somebody who really needs no
introduction however this is one of
those rare occasions we have been very
honored and proud to receive our guests
and do a factory tour where quite a few
people have got to personally meet and
engage with our visitor and it's been a
really fantastic morning for all of us
but without any further ado I would like
to introduce to you the Prime Minister
of the United Kingdom Theresa May
thank you thank you very much a tomorrow
members of parliament will cast their
votes on the withdrawal agreement on the
terms of our departure from the European
Union and the political declaration on
our future relationship that vote in
Westminster is a direct consequence of
the votes that were cast by people here
in Stoke and in cities towns and
villages in every corner of the United
Kingdom in June 2016 the British people
were asked by MPs to take a decision
should the United Kingdom remain a
member of the European Union or should
we leave in that campaign both sides
disagreed on many things but on one
thing they were united what the British
people decided the politicians would
implement in the run-up to the vote the
government sent a leaflet to every
household making the case for remain it
stated very clearly this is your
decision the government will implement
what you decide those were the terms on
which people cast their votes
if majority had backed remain the UK
would have continued as an EU member
state no doubt the disagreements would
have continued too but the vast majority
of people would have had no truck with
an argument that we should leave the EU
in spite of a vote to remain or that we
should return to the question in another
referendum on the rare occasions when
Parliament puts a question to the
British people directly we've always
understood that their response carries a
profound significance when the people of
Wales voted by a margin of naught point
three percent on a turnout of just over
fifty percent to endorse the creation of
the Welsh Assembly that result was
accepted by Parliament indeed we've
never had a referendum in the United
Kingdom that we've not honored the
result of Parliament understood this
fact when it voted overwhelmingly to
trigger article 50 and both major
parties did so - when they stood on
election manifestos in 2017 that pledge
to honor the result of the referendum it
as we've seen over the last few weeks
there are some in Westminster
who would wish to delay or even stop
brexit and who will use every device
available to them to do so I ask them to
consider the consequences there of their
actions on the faith of the British
people in our democracy the House of
Commons did not say to the people of
Scotland or Wales that despite voting in
favor of the devolved legislature
Parliament knew better and would
overrule them or else force them to vote
again what if we found ourselves in a
situation where Parliament tried to take
the UK out of the EU in opposition to a
remain vote people's faith in the
democratic process and their politicians
would suffer catastrophic harm we all
have a duty to implement the result of
the referendum ever since I reached an
agreement with the EU on and withdrawal
agreement and declaration on our future
relationship I've argued that the
consequences of Parliament rejecting it
would be grave uncertainty potentially
leading to one of two outcomes either a
No Deal brexit that would cause
turbulence for our economy create
barriers to security cooperation and
disrupt people's daily lives all the
risk of no brexit at all for the first
time in our history failing to implement
the outcome of a statutory referendum
and letting the British people down
these alternatives both remain in play
if the deal is rejected the refering
views on the threat that are No Deal
exit poses I've always believed that
while we could ultimately make a success
of No Deal it would cause significant
disruption in the short-term and it
would be far better to leave with a good
deal others in the House of Commons take
a different view and regard No Deal is
the ultimate threat to be avoided at all
costs to those people I say this the
only ways to guarantee we do not leave
without a deal are to abandon brexit
betraying the vote of the British people
or to leave with a deal and the only
deal on the table is the one MPs will
vote on tomorrow night you can take no
deal off the table by voting for that
deal and if no deal is as bad as you
believe it is it will be the
height of recklessness to do anything
else but while no deal remains a serious
risk having observed events at
Westminster over the last seven days
it's now my judgment that the more
likely outcome is a paralysis in
Parliament that risks there being no
brexit that makes it even more important
that MPs consider very carefully how
they will vote tomorrow night as I've
said many times the deal we have agreed
is worthy of support for what it
achieves for the British people
immigration policy back in the hands of
people you elect so we can build a
system based around the skills people
have to offer this country not where
they come from and bring the overall
numbers down sovereign control of our
borders decisions about how to spend the
money you pay in taxes back onto the
control of people you elect so we can
spend the vast annual sums we send to
Brussels as we choose on priorities like
our long-term plan for the NHS sovereign
control of our money
UK laws not EU laws governing this
country so the people you elect decide
what the law of the land in our country
is sovereign control of our laws out of
the common agricultural policy with our
farmers supported by schemes we design
to suit our own needs out of the Common
Fisheries Policy so we decide who fishes
in our waters and we can rebuild our
fishing fleets for the future retaking
our seat at the World Trade Organization
so we can strike trade deals around the
world that work for British businesses
and consumers the rights of valued EU
citizens here guaranteed and reciprocal
guarantees for UK citizens across Europe
the partnerships between our police
forces and security services that
protect us every day from threats that
know no borders sustained an
implementation period that ensures our
departure from the EU is smooth and
orderly protecting your jobs and yes a
guarantee that the people of Northern
Ireland can carry on living their lives
just as they do now whatever the future
holds these are valuable prizes
the deal honors the vote in the
referendum by translating the people's
instruction into a detailed and
practical plan for a better future no
one else has put forward an alternative
which does this compare that outcome to
the alternatives of no deal or no brexit
with no deal we would have no
implementation period no security
cooperation no guarantees for UK
citizens overseas no certainty for
businesses and workers here in Stoke and
across the UK and changes to everyday
life in Northern Ireland that would put
the future of our union at risk and with
no brexit as I've said we would risk a
subversion of the democratic process we
will be sending a message from
Westminster to communities like Stoke
that your voices do not count the way to
close off both of these potential
avenues of uncertainty is clear it is
for MPs to back the deal the government
has negotiated and move our country
forward into the bright future that
awaits us I've always believed that
there is a majority in the House of
Commons for a smooth and orderly exit
delivered by means of withdrawal
agreement and that's why the government
tabled the motion for the meaningful
vote last month but it became clear that
MPs concerns about one particular aspect
of the deal the backstop preventing a
hard border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland in the event that we cannot
reach agreement on our new relationship
before the end of the implementation
period meant that there was no prospect
of winning the vote so I suspended the
debate to allow time for further
discussions with the EU to address those
concerns
today I've published the outcome of
those discussions in the form of letters
between the UK government and the
presidents of the European Commission
and European Council I listen very
carefully to the concerns that MPs from
all sides expressed particularly the
concerns of my fellow unionists from
Northern Ireland in my discussions with
the EU we explored a number of the
suggestions made by MPs both about how
the backstop would operate and for how
long the you have said throughout that
they would not renegotiate the
withdrawal agreement or reopen its text
or alteration and that remains the case
throughout my discussions at the
December European Council and since I
also pursued in these discussions a
proposal for a fixed date with legal
force guaranteeing the point at which
the future partnership would come into
force because that is the way to bring
an end to the backstop by agreeing our
new relationship
the --use position was that while they
never want or expect the backstop to
come into force a legal time limit was
not possible but while we did not
achieve that we have secured valuable
new clarifications and assurances to put
before the House of Commons including on
getting our future relationship in place
rapidly so that the backstop should
never need to be used we now have a
commitment from the EU that work on our
new relationship can begin as soon as
possible after the signing of the
withdrawal agreement in advance of the
29th of March and we have an explicit
commitment that this new relationship
does not need to replicate the backstop
in any respect whatsoever we have
agreement on a fast-track process to
bring the free-trade deal we will
negotiate into force if there are any
delays in member states ratifying it
making it even more likely that the
backstop will never need to be used
we now have absolute clarity on the
explicit linkage between the withdrawal
agreement and the political declaration
putting beyond doubt that these come as
a package and finally the EU have
confirmed their acceptance that the UK
can unilaterally deliver on all the
commitments made in our Northern Ireland
paper last week including a Stormont
lock on new EU laws being added to the
backstop and a seat at the table for a
restored Northern Ireland Executive the
legal standing of the significant
conclusions of the December Council have
been confirmed if the backstop were ever
triggered it would only be temporary and
both sides would do all they could to
bring it to an end as quickly as
possible
the letters published today have legal
force and must be used to interpret the
meaning of withdrawal agreement
including in any future arbitration they
make absolutely clear that the backstop
is not a threat or a trap
now I fully understand that the new
legal and political assurances which are
contained in the letters from Donald
Tusk and jean-claude juncker do not go
as far as some MPs would like but I'm
convinced that MPs now have the clearest
assurances that this is the best deal
possible and that it is worthy of their
support to other areas of concern raised
and reflected an amendments tabled to
the meaningful vote were on the
protection of workers rights and on
environmental standards I could not have
been clearer that far from wanting to
see a reduction in our standards in
these areas the UK will instead continue
to be a world leader we've committed to
addressing these concerns and will work
with MPs from across the house on how
best to implement them looking at
legislation where necessary to deliver
the best possible results for workers
across the UK this afternoon I will set
out in greater detail to MPs what is
contained in the correspondence i've
published today and what it means for
our withdrawal and tomorrow I will close
the debate but as we start this crucial
week in our country's history let's take
a step back and remember both what is at
stake and what we stand to gain by
coming together behind this agreement
settle the question of our withdrawal
and we can move on to forging
our new relationship back the deal
tomorrow and that work can start on
Wednesday fail and we risk face the risk
of leaving without a deal or the even
bigger risk of not leaving at all I
think the British people are ready for
us to move on to move beyond division
and come together to move beyond
uncertainty into a brighter future that
is the chance that MPs of all parties
will have tomorrow night and for our
country's sake I urge them to take it
thank you
[Applause]
now I'll take a few questions from the
media Laura and Thank You Prime Minister
BBC News and you seem extremely eager to
move on you say this is a good deal but
you know the majority of your colleagues
simply disagree with you at this late
stage do you really think you have a
chance of changing their minds well I've
been speaking to MPs over the weekend
I'll be back in Parliament today I'll
obviously as I said be making a
statement but I'll also be speaking to
colleagues today and indeed tomorrow
obviously we'll be speaking when I close
the debate tomorrow and I have seen MPs
when I've spoken to them who are now who
recognize the importance of the decision
that is being taken and saying that they
will support the deal whereas perhaps in
the past they had some doubts about it
but obviously we've seen the assurances
that have been published today I believe
those do give more assurance and
confidence to MPs about the nature of
the relationship we will have with the
European Union in the future about the
desire on both sides not to see the
backstop come into force and what we
will both do to ensure that we're
working to make that not happen so that
we can get on to that future
relationship which is the best way of
ensuring a sustainable long term
relationship and dealing with the
Northern Ireland border on that
sustainable long-term basis basis and
the commitments expressed today show
commitment on both sides to get on and
do that Paul news prime minister you've
had two years to reach out to MPs you've
got two days left and virtually nothing
to offer them why shouldn't Parliament
wrestle controller brexit from you well
first of all over the last two years we
have of course been talking with MPs
about the issues that they want to see
raised the issues that they've been
concerned about and the process that
I've been what I've been doing over the
last few weeks over the Christmas and
New Year period is having heard MPs in
December in the debate taking those
issues to the European Union and we have
you say we haven't we
have achieved this exchange of letters
which gives those further clarifications
which gives those further assurances
which I believe are due give that
further confidence to members of
parliament about the future relationship
we'll have with the European Union and
about both sides not wanting to use the
backstop but you talk about
parliamentary taking Parliament taking
control what I think is important is
that we deliver on the result of the
referendum and what I'm concerned about
from what we've seen as I've said in my
speech over the last few days is the
real prospect that we could see as a
stymie in Parliament or Parliament
operating or people in Parliament trying
to operate in a way that frustrates
brexit we have a duty to deliver brexit
and that's what I and the government and
want to do and it's what we are going to
do and I want MPs to recognize that as
well Jack there's a mic Jack Doyle from
The Daily Mail and promised he talks
about workers rights and environmental
standards but are you prepared to go
further to attract the votes of Labour
MPs would you prefer to for example move
on a customs union or any other issues
I've always been clear that we will not
be in the customs union because being in
the customs union has with it so the
other aspects which are not what people
voted for and what people wanted to see
was us able to ensure that we could have
independent trade policy we're working
obviously to ensure that those trade
agreements we're part of as a member of
the EU can be transferred to UK trade
agreements in the future and then what
the opportunity to make those even
better trade agreements for the UK we
can do that by having an independent
trade policy and in order to have that
independent trade policy it means not
being in the customs union our Frances
you have been Prime Minister you've been
very clear about what you say is the
damage to public faith if breaks it
doesn't go ahead at all which has the
most democratic legitimacy the brexit
deal imposed on you by Parliament or a
No Deal brexit that wasn't on the ballot
paper well first of all the
the for those who don't want to see No
Deal as I've said then they have to
agree a deal you talked about a brexit
deal imposed on by parliament actually I
think if you look at what's being said
across Parliament nobody has yet come up
with an alternative brexit deal that is
negotiable and that actually no nobody
has come up with an alternative brexit
deal that is negotiable and that
delivers on the result of the referendum
and that's what we must remember we this
is not just about negotiating a deal
it's about negotiating a deal that
delivers on the result of the referendum
taking back control of money laws and
borders but also ensures that we do it
in a way that maintains jobs maintain
security protects jobs and security and
protects our union and that's what the
deal does do I see Nick from his Nick
Nick from Sky good morning Prime
Minister Nick Martin from Sky News I
just want to add to a question it was
mentioned earlier and it'll perhaps
understand where you are in your own
mind right now as you stand here do you
believe that you can get this through
tomorrow I'm sure you hope you will but
do you actually think you will I'm
working to ensure that we get members of
parliament voting for the deal tomorrow
I believe it is important that we
deliver on this result that we don't see
a situation where there's a risk that
Parliament tries to frustrate brexit I
think over the last few days we've seen
that risk increasing I want to ensure
that we deliver on the referendum that
we leave the European Union and I want
to do it on the basis of a good deal
that protects people's jobs protects our
security and protects our union yes
Prime Minister the EU are offering an
extension of article 50 potentially
until July do you categorically rule
that out I don't think that we're
leaving on the 29th of March I've been
clear that I don't believe we should be
extending article 50 and I don't believe
we should be having in the second
referendum we have that instruction we
haven't from the British people to leave
I believe it's our duty to deliver on
that I want to do it in a way that is
smooth that is orderly as
I've just said protects jobs and
security and protects our union and now
the last one last question I'll take
from Philip Corrigan from the Stoke
Sentinel Phil Corrigan Stoke Sentinel
and you say it's important that people
in stoke-on-trent feel that they're not
being ignored but it seems that most of
the people that are in favor of brexit
don't feel that what you're offering is
brexit and obviously the people are
opposed to brexit don't feel don't
support your deal either so who exactly
are you doing this for well the people
of Stoke I mean the people here in Stoke
guys think voted nearly 70 percent to
leave the European Union and that's what
we're delivering and what I and my
government will be delivering and it's I
think for many people when they voted
obviously people had a number of
different things reasons why they voted
I think there were some key things that
were crucial I think bringing an end to
free movement so he took control of our
borders was one of them I think bringing
an end to the jurisdiction of the
European Court of Justice so we took
back control of our laws was another the
deal delivers on both of those it also
delivers on taking back control of our
money by not sending but continuing to
send vast annual sums of money to the EU
every year and it delivers an
independent trade policy and gets us out
of some of the policies the people have
been concerned about the Common
Agricultural Policy and the Common
Fisheries Policy I think those were the
things that were of concern to people
when they were voting and they wanted us
to be able to have our independent trade
policy and make decisions about who
comes to our country for ourselves for
example and that's exactly what the deal
delivers so I believe it delivers on the
result of the referendum it delivers
brexit but in doing that it would
protect jobs security and our union
thank you
[Applause]